this video is sponsored by Skillshare
the first 500 people to use the link in
the description and get their first two
months free this is the Cavendish banana
or for most of the world just banana
because this one species accounts for
99% of exports and is bought more than
any other item at the grocery store
Walmart's bread and butter isn't
actually bread or butter but bananas and
it's one of the most important crops in
developing countries along with staples
like rice corn and wheat which makes
sense
bananas are nutritious conveniently
packaged by nature and dirt cheap in the
United States bananas cost an average of
just 56 cents a pound roughly 19 cents
each cheap enough that Amazon just gave
them away in Seattle and that's from a
company which literally sells air
oranges in comparison that cost just
over $2 a pound strawberries 334 and
apples $1 62 the difference is bananas
are picky they require extremely rich
soil protection from the wind and lots
of water they can really only grow in
this narrow region about 30 degrees
north or south of the Equator that
eliminates Europe and most of the United
States give or take a volcano an
alligator so if you live here in the
banana Belt a country like Brazil India
or China your bananas are grown locally
for the rest of us they're imported from
Central and South America usually
Ecuador Guatemala or Costa Rica apples
on the other hand take what they can get
they survive in many types of soil and
withstand both cold winters and warm
summer's with not one but thousands of
different varieties so why after being
shipped three or four or 6,000 miles
away are bananas still cheaper than
apples grown a few blocks away
the answer is largely the container the
story of the banana and 90% of
everything we buy is that of the
tainer ship and how it forever changed
the global economy but first let's
rewind there are many ways to get goods
from one place to another planes are
fast trucks are precise and trains are
efficient but water is by far the
cheapest there are no roads to build or
intersections to stop at and once a ship
starts moving it requires very little
attention some of the biggest container
ships in the world are manned by just 13
crew members and companies like
rolls-royce are developing self-driving
versions as we speak the problem until
recently was moving cargo onto and off
of the ship which often took even more
time than actually sailing
that's because workers had to lift carry
and drag everything from barrels to
crates and heavy bags not so fun and not
very fast a journey from New York to
Europe for example might only take 12
days but loading and unloading would
take another seven that's seven full
days it could have spent delivering more
cargo therefore seven full days added to
the cost of shipping port fees dock
workers and their equipment accounted
for sixty to seventy-five percent of the
cost of shipping so by the time a
product reached our shelves its price
would have to be raised an average
twelve percent to make up for it but
everything changed with the container
companies realized they weren't in the
business of shipping bananas or cars or
phones they were in the business of
shipping what's inside the box
shouldn't matter their job is generic
efficient transportation in fact today
crew members don't even know most of
what they're carrying if shipping
companies could take everything and put
it in a single size box they could turn
thousands of individual problems into
just one how to move a known object from
one place to another as quickly as
possible if you're a longshoreman this
is your worst nightmare
your job and in many cases whole coastal
economies were now
based on a repetitive low skill and
easily automated tasks unions of course
fought back at one point a workers
strike lasted 83 days but the universal
law is money finds a way
one company calculated that shortening
the time required to lift a container by
a single second would save $4,000 per
ship per year and they wouldn't be
saving seconds or minutes or even hours
but days containers lowered the cost of
insurance made theft nearly impossible
and allowed for goods to be easily moved
between ship rail and truck the
container was inevitable the only
question was which one for separate
standards organizations of course had
four separate answers but we'll fast
forward years of fascinating debate and
just say the world decided on these
iconic 20 and 40 feet boxes you now see
at every port in every country today
ports are filled not with workers but
giant cranes which move containers in
and out of ships in the most efficient
order possible and ships spend most of
their time in motion the challenge is
keeping containers full the ideal route
goes from A to B where it loads new
cargo for its return back to a but this
isn't always possible China for example
has both high exports and imports
problem is it's manufactured goods are
sent out in container ships but the raw
materials it imports to make them arrive
in bulk cargo ships as a result roughly
60% of containers shipped from Asia to
North America returned empty Australia
is the opposite it exports raw goods
like iron gold and coal but imports its
products on container ships cruise ships
survived by offering repositioning trips
cheaper fares for longer one-way routes
it uses to change regions container
ships don't have that luxury but their
schedules are so predictable that
factories can manufacture goods as they
need them rather than storing large
amounts of inventory in other words
everything is cheap and there's a lot of
it shipping costs are
so low that they almost don't matter the
only thing that does is labor it's this
combination of low wages trivial
shipping costs and tight planning which
turned the banana into the perfect
consumer product it thrives not despite
its limitations but because of them the
journey begins in Ecuador the world's
number one banana exporter thousands of
plantations produce two billion dollars
worth of the fruit every year
bananas are picked while still green in
the first of seven stages and
immediately the clock starts ticking
because once a banana begins to ripen
the process is irreversible worse a
single banana ripening will trigger all
those around it so everything that
happens next is carefully planned to
prevent that first imperfect bananas are
sold locally or fed to livestock the
rest are packed in special containers
called a reefers which keep them at a
controlled 55.9 4 degrees Fahrenheit
before being loaded reefers are sealed
so they won't be exposed to open air
until they reach their destination next
they're transported usually by truck to
the dock where they're loaded 40 or 50
an hour on two ships a large boat can
carry 80 million bananas a whole year's
supply for 600,000 Americans and by
traveling at only 18 or 19 knots they
save millions on their biggest expense
fuel ships may burn 400 tons of Bunker
fuel per day which at current prices
amounts to nearly 200 thousand dollars
in a single 24-hour period
our ship the Dole Pacific makes
deliveries from Ecuador to San Diego all
year round by the time it arrives
bananas have reached stage 2 light green
they're then moved to ripening rooms
where they're sprayed with ethylene gas
to trigger their ripening process once
they reach stage 3 they're ready for
delivery to the grocery store during
this trip they transition from 3 to 4 to
5 when they're finally bought for less
than a quarter with a single uniform
variety
groan where labor is cheap and sold in
high-value consumer markets bananas
perfectly represent the efficiency of
global shipping the beauty of container
ships is their ability to conveniently
deliver goods regardless of where the
digital equivalent is today's sponsor
Skillshare which delivers knowledge on
all kinds of topics when and where you
want if you're interested in learning
how the stock market works for example
you should take this great course from
business casual if you want to know how
I make these videos you can watch the
course I made how to make an animated
YouTube video I go over everything from
my research to the script writing and
animation I've even included example
files which you can download with the
course and follow along the first 500
people to use the link in the
description get two months free so you
can watch my course and any of over
twenty thousand others available on
Skillshare